well i think in for novices and guys
especially white comedy starting out uh
back when i started
we were going off death jam and showtime
at the apollo
and so if you've never been to a a
comedy show with a lot of black people
it gives you the impression it's going
to be rowdy as [__]
you know what i mean right whereas you
know
i think black people just they don't
have any skeletons in the closet
it's just like tell us your life and
we'll let you know if we like it or not
and there's no there's no like i've
i've never seen a black crowd get
offended hmm
that's like the though it seems like
we're in this cancel culture you know
listen you ain't ever seen
uh urban audience a black audience get
mad because you said a
a certain word outside of the n-word as
a white dude right
that you can't say but as far as like
talking about a special needs cousin
or an overweight uh you know relative
or a feminine person black audiences
they don't care they're like yeah i know
that person
that's real life i think more so with
white audiences uh you know weren't as
i've never seen it like in my career or
where comedians have to apologize
for jokes or something we said you know
a lot of times they're sticking these
cell phones into shows and
we're working a bit out and all of a
sudden it's on the internet you're like
dude i was working something out there
that must be so bizarre for like you
doing comedy over 20 years to see
the evolution of comedy become like
where comedians are almost
afraid to like take a risk now or say
something for fear of blowback
well i don't think it's like that in the
clubs
um i think live comedy is still
it's fine people go there to hear the
uncomfortable
and but it's when somebody takes their
phone out
and puts it on the internet but as far
as like
uh just going to a live show it's
rare you see somebody get up and get
upset
rare and i've never i've never
i've never seen a black person get up
and leave because they were offended
by a joke i've seen black people get
kicked out because they were heckling
but i've never seen electricity
if you go on the internet and google
like people walking out of comedy shows
you don't ever see a black couple or a
black person just walking out
yeah they'll heckle but they're not
gonna walk out
you know i had a i had a i did a club in
jacksonville florida and like the only
white
couple in there was the white lady
walked out complaining i was racist
against white people
so that just
[Music]
[Laughter]
makes no sense yeah it did it didn't at
all especially like yeah i'm
i'm just like blonde hair blue eyes you
know we're like the
the too white to fail white but yet we
can still translate
but that's her that would be her own
insecurities yeah
yeah what is what has been your
experience
with um like white rooms because in
researching you have heard
you know the early stories you getting
like a band from the comedy story your
first time there and
i know like netflix has said no to you
and comedy central
like is there maybe this is more of the
question because
acceptance is something i've had to
really struggle with
and even if it's why didn't that cool
open mic book me
all the way to you know why didn't i get
this opportunity why him not me type
deal
how have you been able to kind of like
are you have you conquered that or is
that something you still struggle with
is that acceptance
i mean i mean i think everybody wants to
the there's still
nothing like having a comedy special
getting released on a network whether
it's netflix
hbo showtime conversational it's it's
still a good feeling it's a sense of
accomplishment but we're also in a day
and age where you can put your own stuff
out on youtube
and young comics i mean i you know i i'm
learning this
even though i'm in 20 years in i'm
starting to treat youtube like
a tv network it's like your own tv
network
and you have complete control over it
thanks for watching hot breath the verse
if you want to support the show go join
our patreon but if you don't like
supporting a comic on the hustle
at least click to watch more videos to
keep us alive
in the algorithm